hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et tu tapes le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
est-ce que vous avez déjà sauvé une
personne de la noyade moi oui
non vraiment pas bah voila a alors
encore s'est passé oui alors j'aime pas
raconter cette histoire parce que ça
fait je me la raconte mais on va aller
la raconter j'étais avec un ami on le
dans une maison très luxueuse super mois
à la piscine son petit gamin de 3 ans y
va dans l'eau avec personne ne le
remarque parce qu'elle était dans l'eau
direct on était en train de poser de
serviettes et on se retourne et alpiq
est sous l'eau et le bleu et son père
pierre le garde pas moi off j'enlève ma
veste je jette mon portable je plonge
super beau gosse je prends le petit
voile et je le sors et je les embrasse
s'il me regarder son papa sam aussi j'ai
fait ça de ma vie
[Applaudissements]
valero